النساء يجهزنا الطعام في منازلهم والعمال
منتشرون باشغالهم في المصانع والمزارع
والحياه تدب في المدينه الايرانيه التي
تعد من اهم موارد الاقتصاد في ايران وسط
اجواء استثنائيه يفرضها شهر رمضان الذي لم
يكن في عام 2012 كاي رمضان سبقه عندما
كانت هذه المدينه الاقتصاديه على موعد مع
كارثه هي الاكثر دمويه في تاريخ البلاد
زلزال تبريز الكبير
فما قصته
كانت الساعه الثانيه عشر وعشرين دقيقه
صباحا عندما تسبب نشاط صدع كبير شمل تبريز
عاصمه اذربيجان في سلسله من الهزات
الارتداديه التي امتدت حتى صباح اليوم
التالي وفقا للارقام الرسميه تم قياس
الزلزالين رئيسيين بقوه 6 درجات
على مقياس رتر تلتهما 55 هزه ارتداديه
قدرت قوه اخطرها باربع درجات فاصله ثمانيه
رختر
تهدمت العديد من الابنيه لم يعد هنا اي
حياته بالمدينه جثه دفنت تحت الانقاض
واخرون ممددون على الطريق ربما بينهم بعض
الاحياء
وفيما تاخر وصول فرق الاغاثه الحكوميه
للمساعده نحو سبع ساعات تحول النجون
لخلايا نحل منهم من يساعد مصابا ومنهم من
ينتشر جثه ومنهم
يبحث عن اقاربه
تقطعت الطرق وانقطعت الاتصالات بشكل كامل
وانقطعت امدادات الطاقه عن نحو 70 قريه
محيطه بسبب تضرر خطوط انابيب الغاز
الطبيعي وفي تبريز فقدت الطاقه الكهربائيه
لساعات وفي بعض الاحيان لم يتمكن رجال
الانقاذ من الوصول الى بعض القرى الا عن
طريق الجو
تسببت الكارثه في مقتل 300 وسته اشخاص
واصابه المئات فيما ان 70% من الضحايا
كانوا من الاطفال والنساء كما ان معظم
المصابين بجروح خطيره هم من الاطفال دون
سن التاسعه اضافه الى الحاق اضرار جسيمه
بما يقرب من اثني عشر منزل فيما قدر عدد
المتاثرين باكثر من
1757,000 شخص
جميله الاضرار 440 قريه تعرضت جميعها
لابرار هيكليه تتراوح بين اربعين في المئه
ومئه في المئه في ما عانه البلدات
المنكوبه من نقص مياه الشرب والطعام
والخيام والبطانيات
في اليوم التالي استيقظ الكثير من
الايرانيين على انباء الزلزال المدمر
بينما تضافرت جهود المتطوعين مع المنظمات
غير الرسميه في اغاثه المتضررين وتجهيز
الملاجل فسارع الكثيرون للتبرع بالدم
والنقود والضروريات بالمقابل قرر البعض
السفر الى المنطقه للحصول على اخبار من
عائلاتهم واحبائهم
حوفرت ذكرى مؤلمه في قلوب الايرانيين فهم
لم يفقدوا احبائهم واقاربهم فحسب بل كشفت
ايضا عن ان هذه المدينه الغنيه بالموروثات
الثقافيه والمعالم الحضاريه التي يعد
نشاطها التجاري والصناعي جزءا من الاقتصاد
الوطني تنهار غالبيه بنيتها التحتيه بسبب
زلزال وصلت قوته الى ست درجات
[موسيقى]